[Music]
after Avatar in 2009 it took 13 years to
make Avatar 2 the way of water
originally Avatar 3 and the other
sequels were supposed to be released a
little quicker but that won't happen
anymore since the whole movie series has
been massively postponed up to 2031. the
extensive release postponements at
Disney do not spare James Cameron's
Blockbuster series either after Avatar 3
was scheduled for December 19 2024 until
recently the film will now be released a
year later on December 19 2025. the
other movies will be hit even harder as
Parts 4 and 5 will be delayed by three
years Avatar 4 is now slated for
December 21st 2029 and Avatar 5 for
December 19 2031 22 years after the
first Avatar film as a small consolation
producer John Landau released a first
behind the scenes photo of avatar 3. on
it we can see a monitor on set showing
how the actors are already being
replaced live on location with a rough
version of the navi it is definitely a
good tool for the creative minds behind
the camera should there not be further
postponements like with Avatar 2 the way
of water we'll see at the end of 2025
whether the effort was worth it we'll
keep our fingers crossed
[Music]
thank you